[Music]
welcome to the home scream home Van
Purina
stole our hearts but just how much do
you know about the show well stay tuned
until the end for some fabulous news
about this adorable Disney jr. program
we definitely didn't have anything like
this in Transylvania don't forget to hit
that notification bellow to never miss
another video and be sure to check out
our community section for even more fun
let's get started based on the books did
you know that vamp arena is actually
based on the most adorable children's
book you'll ever read the book is called
vamp arena ballerina by anne-marie pace
and if you loved the show you absolutely
have to read the book especially if you
have kids as the title might suggest the
book is all about a girl vampire that's
also a ballerina although the show has a
completely different storyline and
slightly different characters you can
still draw some similarities between the
two the book has an adorable story of a
vampire kid who's just trying to learn
how to dance but because the little girl
is a vampire she needs to find a class
that runs at night vamp arena has
another unexpected challenge she needs
to find out how to dance without seeing
herself in the mirror after all vampires
don't have a reflection do they vamp
arena also has to learn to love pink a
color she really doesn't like and of
course she has to control her urges to
bite her fellow dancers as well as
control her stage fright it might seem
like a book for adults but we guarantee
it
it's totally adorable vamp arenas
secrets as of 2018 vamp arena has been
running for two seasons and that means
we learned a lot about this vampire kid
and her friends but we bet you never
managed to cut to these secrets over the
two seasons we have learned that B is a
left-handed vampire truth be told it's
not really clear whether this is a trait
all vampires possess so it's interesting
we get to learn that about V but in
season 1 episode 20 a we also learned
that B is only scared of one thing baby
cals seriously we're not kidding
it's how her friends get her hiccups to
stop but why is she afraid of baby cows
well it turns out that it happens back
when she was just a baby and not used to
flying her family was on one of their
night flights and because
he was so tiny she got carried off by
wind she ended up in a field of baby
cows now that must have been terrifying
right in this particular episode her
friends pull quite a mean trick on her
it's clear that B has some trauma from
her flying experience but she also has
the hiccups and her friends are helping
her to get rid of them so of course they
want to scare her and they do that by
turning the lounge into a barn full of
stuffed baby cows needless to say that
vamp arena got ridiculously scared her
hiccups went away but was this really
the best way to do that Boris is played
by james van der beek forest is vamper
anna's cool father he's pretty much a
typical father figure you can find in
any classic show who could have known
that vampires are actually this relaxed
and cool right but Boris has another
secret he's actually played by the one
and only james van der beek the name
might not ring any bells if you're
younger but 90s kids will definitely
remember him he played Dawson on the one
and only classic show Dawson's Creek
things changed Dawson evolved Disney jr.
may have had a lot of shows in the past
but this is James's debut series and
he's definitely doing a good job he also
seems very fond of his dad character his
description of Boris says that he's the
kind of dad you'd always roll your eyes
at but you also can't help but love him
because he's such a good guy he's going
there sounds about right doesn't it we
love Boris but we also love the fact
that this is one of the few times you
can hear James sing and he's definitely
not bad at it either vamper inna toys
are a huge hit if you're new to vamp
arena you might be in for quite a
surprise sure the show's only had two
seasons but don't doubt its popularity
among the juniors Disney definitely knew
what it was doing when they created this
show and it looks like it paid off not
only can you watch vamp Arena on screen
you can also play with the characters in
real life like many other shows vamp
arena also came out with merch and it's
proven to be very popular whoever your
fave is you can probably get a toy
version of it in stores and not just a
version of your characters Disney also
sells vamp arena castles boom boxes and
pretty much anything else you can think
of if you're a huge fan and need just a
little bit more of a marina
your life definitely check out the
selection of toys our faith has to be
vamp rhiness castle it's pretty obvious
that van Breanna merch is in full swing
and you better make sure to get yourself
a little something we're pretty sure it
will only grow as we get more and more
into the seasons what would you choose
miss cuttle cakes we bet you never knew
about this secret connection miss cuttle
cakes has with another show in case you
need to refresh your memory let's talk a
bit about this adorable cat she belongs
to Bridget's V's best friends and yep
this cat is totally hairless we're not
sure how you feel about hairless cats
but let's be honest it's a perfect breed
choice for a show about vampires
sure Bridget might not be a vampire but
this definitely makes sense
okay so what's miss cuddle cakes his
secrets it has to do with the creator of
vamp arena christening as it turns out
Chris borrow - miss cuddle cakes named
from another show well sort of it was
still his show and he just ended up
taking the character yep an actual
character not just a name you can find
miss cuddle cakes in the doc McStuffins
show it's definitely not a coincidence
that both shows have the same creator
who just so happened to borrow the name
of the adorable cat of course the
hairless miss cuddle cakes is still
one-of-a-kind let's just hope that doc
McStuffins cat didn't actually end up
hairless and become miss cuddle cakes
from vamp arena that might be just a bit
too dark for a kids show don't you think
Gilmore Girls wait what do Gilmore Girls
have to do with vamper Anna well as it
turns out plenty one of the most
surprising things about this show is the
fact that we get to see some of our
favorite old-school actors
well maybe not see them but we do get to
hear them you might not know them but
every 90s kid remembers Lorelai Gilmore
from Gilmore Girls and guess who plays
Oksana hotly in vamp Arena the exact
same person her name is Lauren Graham
this talented actress is also one of the
most hilarious people you'll ever meet
she has won six awards during her
lifetime and was nominated for another
19 that's pretty impressive right well
around 2017 rumor had it that her role
in vamp arena could finally bring her
home an Emmy of course so far that
hasn't happened but who knows we
absolutely love her in vamp arena and we
definitely think Lauren
Grahame deserves an emmy-award of her
own her best work will forever remain
Gilmore Girls
but who knows maybe van morena will
become the second best vamp Arenas
talents let's check out some more
secrets B is hiding from you guys or
should we say Isabella because that's
who gives B her voice
Isabella cravette E is an adorable
actress with a bright future ahead of
her with parents working in the movie
industry
Isabella started acting very young
seriously just check out her impressive
acting CV on IMDB this girl has had over
20 roles before she got her gig as
beyond vamp arena we loved her adorable
voice and she definitely does a good job
at portraying her character doesn't she
she's definitely talented her biography
says that she started booking acting
gigs and commercials within a month of
signing to a talent agency
she's pretty impressive right if you
watch the right movies you might also
find her family on the big screen her
twin brothers played Nicole Kidman's
kids in big little lies they're
definitely a talented family aren't they
we're pretty sure that's not the last
we'll hear about this family either
Isabella already has roles books for
2019 and we honestly can't wait to see
her on our screens again Evan Almighty
there's another secret that unexpectedly
ties to characters Greg gorya might take
care of be with her parents are away but
as it turns out she has a secret with
Oksana or should we say Lauren Graham
and Wanda Sykes have a secret they both
appeared in the hilarious movie known as
Evan Almighty although we don't see them
interact much in vamp arena Lauren and
Wanda definitely interacted in Evan
Almighty and they were actually pretty
hilarious yup they got to work with
Steve Carell and Morgan Freeman
seriously if you've never seen this
movie you definitely have to check it
out we love finding out unexpected
connections between actors Wanda Sykes
is also in a show called blackish and
you can also find her in tons of movies
she also played the character granny in
Ice Age
can we say how thrilled we are to see
you seriously you know vamp arena is
good when it has this many good actors
and we bet the vamp Reena actors have
even more connections than we know it's
just one of those things you can never
know unless you take the time to find
the information but don't worry we're
here to make
easier for you bridget is just as
adorable in real life speaking of actors
let's check out the actress that plays
Bridget's bridget is Bea's best friend
and the second human to learn what V
actually is it's sometimes very
surprising to find out the truth about
your best friends but Bridget's just too
cool for school
we love her her character look
definitely makes her stand out from the
rest but guess what
Bridget is just as adorable in real life
her voice belongs to a young actress
known as Vivienne Yi sure she might not
have big orange glasses or orange hair
but she's definitely her own version of
adorable just look at her we can
definitely see that she has Bridget's
playful and silly side of course she
does she pretty much is Bridget isn't
she
malinka cousin full of spiders you've
probably even heard her voice before
Vivienne placed Stacey in the boss baby
and you know how much we love the boss
baby
just like Isabella Vivian also has a
pretty impressive resume for someone her
age we're telling you young actors will
take over Hollywood these people are so
talented we're seriously impressed but
seriously isn't Vivienne the cutest
thing you've ever seen
talented and adorable at the same time
there will be more Disney Junior shows
Disney's vamper inna is popular like
it's really really popular if you just
stumbled on this video and decided to
keep on watching you might not even
believe how popular this show is we'll
break it down for you don't worry it
might be surprising just how many young
fans this show has but after you watch a
couple of episodes you'll definitely
understand the appeal although it
features slightly unusual characters
vamp arena is all about belonging as an
outsider on top of that it features
plenty of educational elements that are
definitely useful for youngsters and
guess what Disney Junior realized the
potential of these shows and promised to
roll out even more programs for kids on
September 9th 2018 Disney ordered more
vamp arena episodes which means we'll
likely get season 3 and perhaps even
season 4 it's been reported that vamp
arena Muppet Babies and puppy dogs pals
reached an average of 515 million
households which is pretty impressive
it's definitely amazing that Disney
finally put focus on the smallest
members of its audience
we love Disney shows for teenagers but
you can't deny that vamp arenas just the
cutest what do you think do you love
this show
hate it let's discuss in the comments
below and that's it for our video don't
forget to subscribe to the things for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]